shock poll shows RFK Jr's run as an
independent could pull more support from
Trump than Biden in 2024 and the poll
basically shows it asks if you have a
favorable view of RFK Jr and they find
that Republicans actually have a more
favorable view than Independence and
Democrats Democrats have a very
relatively unfavorable view of RFK Jr of
course we're hearing now that he may run
as an independent but I actually want to
say right away I think this is wrong
Republicans have favorable views of Viv
gramas Swami they're voting Trump they
have a favorable view of RFK Jr they are
voting Trump as Phil leonti said last
week Trump's bottom is Rock Solid and I
think that's it could probably be
phrased a lot better but his voter floor
is not going to move 44% of whatever
individuals who support Trump ain't
going to back anybody else and I like RK
Jr I have a favorable view of him I'm
not voting for him right I I agree with
that yeah I think this the daily mail's
view is wrong I think the poll is
interesting for sure but I think they're
wrong if you look at Independence 36 to
37 it's it's within the margin of error
the question is how many independent
voters who would normally vote Democrat
will end up voting RFK Jr instead and
will that Spike Joe Biden I give very oh
real quick Rich bars came on the show
and said if RFK Jr runs it could be a
Ross per like moment and Trump could end
up winning States like Maine because he
because it'll split enough of the
Democrats and it could he Trump could
end up winning uh uh the presidency with
like 43 44% of the popular vote yeah
that's what happened with Abraham with
Lincoln we talked about that it was a
four-way split four part I don't like
where this is going um I don't trust
polls firstly because they can be used
to manipulate public perception I don't
and I I hate to be the guy that
constantly asks but how many people were
pulled here this like a thousand people
and then they extrapolated thousand and
then they tell you that it it stands for
300 million and it's like no it stands
for a thousand well they also didn't ask
would you vote for him they asked Tim
what you said the favorable versus
unfavorable I have a generally favorable
view of RFK Jr I like that he posts
workout videos I sometimes post a
workout video I'm okay with that I think
a lot of Republicans like him because he
called out the Democrats for a lot of
their crazy nonsense that everybody can
see is insane and he was like yeah I
don't agree with that or hey I don't
know maybe you shouldn't be forced to
have a vaccine that's why I think a lot
of Republicans have a favorable view but
you're right the Trump Bas I don't
believe going anywhere but you I mean
and you had people saying Trump RFK Jr
2024 I've heard that yeah and it's like
okay well probably not but people like
the anti-establishment and I think that
shows you even though RFK Jr has had
anti-2a sentiments in the past the one
of the biggest issues in the election in
2016 2020 now even the midterms is
anti-establishment versus establishment
if you're RFK Jr and you say the machine
is broken and I have these political
views people will be like I care less
about your policy positions and more
about your your your opposition to the
corruption in in Congress and DC in the
federal government there was there was
an article released um a couple days ago
highlighting how Hillary Clinton was
warning Joe Biden in a private meeting
that a third- Party candidate would
quote prove disastrous for him as a
White House Insider caus the situation
pretty effing concerning this is the
reporting from The Daily Mail that just
happened a couple days ago so I I I
think you know it is interesting to to
see RFK Jr to see where he's going to be
going allegedly he's going to be
announcing on uh October 9th in
Pennsylvania an independent run that's
the rumors that are circulating right
now I don't know if that's true or not
but there is a very big Stark difference
between RFK Jr and Donald Trump
especially when it comes to coid their
response to co their response to uh
operation warp speed and we have to
understand here Donald Trump was advised
by RFK Jr and was going to launch an
investigation into uh these medical
procedures that people get injected with
and uh then uh Donald Trump decided to
take the advice of Bill Gates and not
listen to RFK Jr and not do that
investigation now a a a trump RFK Jr
ticket I think would would would uh ease
a lot of the concerns of a lot of
anti-establishment people what
percentage do you think it's possible
that there could be a trump RFK Jr
presidency oh I I don't want to say
super high percentage to be honest with
you but it's funny because people ask me
all the time well who's he considering
as a running mate who anybody on the
debate stage and the truth is he's kept
this one pretty close to the vest I will
say um and so I don't know who he who
he's considering and I don't know RFK Jr
probably are there considerations I'm
sure there are absolutely he's
considering things multiple things at
all times if if you're thinking about a
ticket that says screw you establishment
I think it is a trump RFK Jr ticket and
I think it would ease a lot of the fears
about a new potential coid virus coming
back under his presidency if RFK Jr was
there saying hey I'm here as vice
president I here will stand up for the
people and for people's own ump
individual rights for their bodies to
choose what they want to do with them I
I agree but I just think there's there's
way too much political baggage for that
to happen a lot a lot of people have
entertained it but I suppose the the
bigger issue is I don't know who Trump
could pick as a running mate we we we've
said a lot of people thought it would be
to santis for a long time and now that's
completely
not happening uh V ramaswami but he says
he doesn't want to be VP but he has to
say that but I don't even know if he
would be the right pick some people are
saying chrisye N I have no idea it can't
be someone close to his views and his
kind of overall messaging it has to be
someone polar opposite there's a reason
he picked Mike Pence the neocon well
there there's a reason Biden uh uh was
was chosen for Obama why Obama chose bid
they're completely different from each
other so if if Trump has a choice right
now between Rhino between a Mike Pence
kind of candidate for his vice
presidency or a a Democrat maybe even a
Tulsi gabard or or an RFK Jr I think
picking a a Democrat will help him out
more than picking a Ryo neoconservative
which clearly especially what happened
today a lot of people have disdain for
it yes and I I saw a Twitter poll from I
can't remember who it was but it was
like 10,000 or so votes and I was
surprised to see uh Tulsi gabard got
more votes it's not a scientific poll
I'm just talking about Twitter then uh
uh then VI then RFK Jr people thought
Tulsi gabard would be a good pick I like
Tulsi gabard yeah she's military right
she and she's positioning herself in a
very curious way doing media appearances
speaking tours in a way where she's kind
of running but not running I got to be
honest like you know when I think about
gnome I think about RFK Jr V I'm kind of
like I don't know I don't think it's I
don't think telsey gabard has uh uh in
my mind a substantially higher
percentage but it does seem to make more
sense he's going to get a lot of
moderate old school and post- liberal
types who are going to be like with
gabard there I I I I I'm I'm willing to
support this yeah there still is a kind
of Bernie bro sentiment within the
Democratic party of of not liking the
establishment there still is the kind of
Jimmy doors out there the Russell Brands
out there that do Glenn green rald that
do represent kind of a leftist kind of
anti-establishment
ideology that that could Galvanize a lot
of votes and I think would be more
popular than in neon Joe
said now twice on his show he would vote
for Trump over Joe Biden Joe Biden is
not there he hasn't gone as far say I'm
going to vote for Trump he was like if
it was Trump Biden I'd vote for Trump
over Biden I think if you had a trump
gabard ticket and again this is we're
just we're just spitting in the wi here
I mean it's all just silly nonsense it's
probably meaningless in the big picture
but just thinking about it now I think
he's Joe's friends with Tulsi I think
you had a trump gabard ticket Joe's
going to be like I'm voting for Trump
tuls I'm Trump gabard tuls is my friend
I I trust her yeah you need someone you
need someone that's going to Galvanize
more people outside of his base that are
going to vote for him as the VP ticket
so but I don't even want to entertain
that right because it's just like it's
silly conversation I mean 6 months from
now he's going to pick someone you're
back oh but it could be that you're just
offering ideas that eventually get
around to Don and then that's true no I
hope that there is someone here who who
knows him I'm just saying to
go see gab he like that's a good idea
cuz the baggage about R I like your
impression I think it was like two days
after he announced he was running the
it's an antiva really big on a news
article about him and they hadn't said
that about RFK before that and it was
right when he announced I was like I got
to call my mom get her before the
brainwashing hits because once people
get brainwashed it's harder to
un-brainwash them so when you know it's
coming you tell your loved ones right
away and then when they see it they're
like oh he was right and they're ready
that and that's what the media is trying
to do to you they're like we got to
we've got to Poison the Well in RFK Jr
before people can talk to their family
about it exactly and there was a
coordinated attack against RFK J now
he's he's in a very interesting position
because he also made some very
interesting statements about the border
which a lot of Democrats aren't really
making right now he did flip-flop on the
Second Amendment he has been pretty
solid on his bodily uh autonomy uh that
he's been standing for almost his entire
life so he's positioning himself in a
very interesting way where he's not far
left and he's not far right but he is
anti-establishment which Trump is as
well here's a question I mean we just
got a super chat from Ginger MacIsaac
saying Larry Elder for VP what do you
guys think about that he did really well
in California I like Larry Elder yeah I
think he's a he's a great guy I don't
know enough about him to he's too
similar to Trump problem you have a lot
of alpha energy there on both kind of
yeah it's a hard question I have to
imagine uh uh Trump is strategically you
also want to have someone that if they
impeach you you want to make sure that
they're not going to be more favorable
than you are so you also want a horrible
person like Mike Pence in there or Cala
Harris and and that's why vice president
or or Joe Biden and that's why all the
vice presidents are horrible Dick Cheney
look at all the vice presidents they're
horrible human beings every last one of
them thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net